- Today I'm going to answer your questions
on career and coinciding topics.
On my Instagram channel, Firm Learning,
I recently asked you
to submit the questions
that you want to have answered by me.
I already directly answered many of them
on my Instagram channel,
but still, there were some questions
that many people asked.
And I want to use this video
to answer these questions
for this broader audience
because I know and I trust
that many of you guys
are asking yourself the same questions.
So welcome to another coffee break here
on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich,
and here on my channel Firm Learning,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your careers.
So I will now always
read out the questions
here on my phone.
And the first question is,
can non native Germans enter
into McKinsey in Germany
with C1 level German?
And hear questions like this
not always I will answer
with a more general type of approach.
So not talking about specific firms,
but rather, for instance,
NBB firms in general.
And the answer here is that, yes,
you do not need to be a native German
to work at a German MBB firm.
And this is true for most other
European countries as well.
Indeed, the two requirements
that will be required from you,
are first, that usually you will need
to have a valid work permit,
a valid work visa,
to actually be able to
work in the country.
And second, you will need
to have local language skills.
So not necessarily on a native level,
but at least on a business
proficiency level.
So C1 should usually qualify for that.
Next question.
Is it worth doing an MBA
even though I have a PhD
and three years of consulting experience?
And here now I want to generalize this
to the question,
is it worth to do an MBA
especially if you already have lots
of academic experience?
And here I'd say it very much depends
on your goals.
So usually, just to
advance in your career,
I do not think that an MBA
is necessarily required.
However, an MBA can help us
to make a transition in your career.
So whenever you feel like you are stuck
in a specific area
in your career,
then the NBA is like the Joker card
that you can pull out once in your life,
and that can really help you
to make that transition.
And I already once made
a video about that,
how exactly this works.
I will link it somewhere above here.
So check it out to learn more about this.
Is it possible
to get into MBB
with an extremely low GPA,
and I have three years of experience?
So let's just say it will
be extremely difficult,
especially if your GPA
is really low.
So I'd say if your GPA may be
as average but not super stellar,
then it already will be tough.
But probably you can compensate
that of some other parts of your profile
and really stand up.
But if your GPA is really low,
then again, I don't want
to say it's impossible.
Maybe if you're really a genius,
a superstar,
this comes through to your application
by other areas of your profile,
then maybe you have a shot.
But for most people,
I consider it really difficult
and probably unfortunately not realistic.
How would you go about
getting an internship
at one of the big four consulting firms?
And here, I don't think there's some kind
of magic trick that you
need to have, right.
And what you need to understand
is that these firms
often have highly professional
recruiting processes.
So while of course,
it might help if you
already know a consultant,
and you can then directly forward
your application to HR,
you should be able to assume
that with these firms,
you can just apply via the online form
and your application will
be treated professionally.
And if you fulfill the criteria,
then you will be invited.
And indeed, when I applied to NBB,
I always just used the
regular application form.
I didn't have any insight
or contacts in these firms.
And this worked out really well for me,
and it will work for you as well,
if you fulfill of course the criteria.
How hard is it to get
in McKinsey after your bachelor?
And indeed not generalizing it,
not for all the NBB firms.
So usually, you can assume
that if you have a bachelor,
the hurdles to get in
are pretty similar
than if you have a pre-experience master.
Therefore, it can be a bit tougher
to get in with only a bachelor
because the criteria
against you are measured
and very similar compared to
if you start with a master.
But as it will be one or two years earlier
in your development both
from the personal side
that maybe also from the internship
that you have completed,
you will need to have achieved more
in the rather short time
span of the bachelor
to be invited to the interview
and then to get in.
Therefore, it's not impossible.
But yes, I guess you can argue
that it's a bit more challenging.
Are MBA's mandatory
to get into MBB?
No, not at all.
This is not at all mandatory.
And especially in countries like Germany,
MBAs are still quite uncommon.
Just most people don't do an MBA.
So people are regularly hired
at MBB firms without an MBA.
But even in the US
or other countries where MBAs
are more common,
you can absolutely start
with a bad shot,
with an undergraduate degree
in a business analyst position
and you will get in.
And an MBA by no means
is a hard requirement.
What is the best book
that I've read recently?
So here are
I can recommend you
to check out my book recommendations,
you find a link to that below
in the video description,
there are link to a page
with all the books
that I can really recommend.
And of course,
some of them I've also read recently.
Do you think there might be a valid reason
to go for Tier Two instead of a Tier One?
So here, of course,
people might have very personal reasons
to choose certain firms.
And of course,
personal fit might play a role as well.
But I believe that for most candidates,
there's not really a reason
why you should join a Tier Two
if you have the opportunity
to join a Tier One.
And the reason is that
in terms of work-life balance,
in terms of overall working experience,
they are quite similar.
But in Tier One firms,
you will often have the opportunity
to work for slightly more relevant
and important projects.
Also, the support that you get
via the whole back office
infrastructure is larger,
so you can focus more as a consultant
on the key coinciding topics.
And lastly, the brand value for your CV,
but also your exit opportunities
after your work
will be slightly better
in Tier One firms compared
to Tier Two firms.
This is at least my opinion.
What are the advantages or disadvantages
of doing a master?
And here I think the
answer is pretty similar
to advantages or disadvantages
of doing an MBA,
and here are also a video
about that about that.
I will link it somewhere here above.
But in generally the cost
of doing a master are twofold.
First, it's an investment of time.
And second, it's an investment of money.
So you need to ask yourself
whether these two types of investments
are worth it.
Investment of time will
usually be compensated
if you're able to start one step higher,
if you start in the workforce
with a master compared to a bachelor.
And at least for the consulting firms,
this is usually the case,
usually you start
one level higher with a master.
And therefore you can compensate
for the loss of time
by already being one step further ahead
in your career journey.
Especially if you work
in a private university,
you will need to pay student fees.
But then the second factor of it is also
that in this time,
you will not earn money,
So you'll miss the salary.
So this of course can add up
to quite a high sum.
But again, if the master
opens up career opportunities for you,
which might have not been available
with your bachelor,
or maybe also the knowledge
that you acquire via your master
will then really help you
to be successful in the long term.
And this might easily be over compensated
throughout the lifespan
of your career.
So keep these two things in mind.
But my personal opinion is
that if you do a master
at a target university
with good grades,
usually this will be worth the investment
in the long term in most cases.
What do I do for a living?
Did I quit consulting?
And if Yes, why?
So yes, I quit consulting
about a year ago,
I worked with McKinsey,
but now left the firm since then.
And the reasons I
detailed in another video
where I talk about what things are
that I didn't learn in consulting,
and I will also link it somewhere above.
So overall, I'm super grateful
and thankful for former time at MBB.
It was an amazing experience.
And I do believe
that consulting is a great career choice
for many young business
graduates out there.
But still I felt that after these years
I wanted to do something
slightly more operationally.
So I joined a German retail company
in a CTO position.
So I'm working in this new career
since about a year,
and of course in parallel I also started
this YouTube channel.
If you have more questions
that we're not answered
here in this video,
feel free to leave me a comment below
in the comment section.
And I will do my very best
to answer every single one.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please smash the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to this channel
to stay up to date on my content.
I release weekly videos
every single Saturday.
If you want to see even more from me
and potentially also contribute
to future Q&A sessions,
you can follow me on my Instagram.
My handle is Firm Learning.
And I also have a mailing list
you can find a sign up link
to that mailing list below
in the video description.
I want to take a moment also
thank all the sponsors
of my channel.
Without all of you guys
it wouldn't be possible what I do.
So thank you so much.
And if you're thinking about
becoming a sponsor as well
and get access to some great member-only,
sponsor-only perks,
you can sign up via the Join button
that is next to the subscribe button.
So have a look at that.
I'd love you to become a member
and I would be super
thankful for your support.
So big thanks to all of you for watching.
I very much appreciate it,
and I'll see you again next Saturday.
Bye bye.